[Música]
Cómo se hizo famoso Drácula después de
más de 100 años de la muerte de su
Creador Drácula sigue siendo el vampiro
más famoso de la historia
pero este noble transilvano no fue el
primer vampiro ni el más popular de su
época y podría haber quedado olvidado de
no ser por un giro del destino la
primera aparición de Drácula fue en la
novela de bram stoker en 1897 pero eso
fue mucho Después de la aparición de los
mitos de vampiros ya había monstruos
chupasangre unos 800 años antes de esta
fecha fue la cultura eslava la que nos
dio la palabra vampiro opir en ruso
antigua la primera mención escrita del
término se hizo en el siglo 11 la
cultura de vampiros de la región
precedió al cristianismo y persistió a
pesar del esfuerzo de la iglesia por
eliminar cultos paganos las historias de
vampiros se originaron en la
interpretación errónea de muertes por
rabia pelagra y descomposición en este
último caso los gases hinchaban el
cuerpo y la sangre salía por la boca lo
que hacían un cuerpo parecer hubiera
estado vivo y comiendo recientemente los
vampiros se describían como hinchados
con dientes y uñas largos de más esto
dio lugar a muchos rituales para
prevenir que los muertos se le basen
como enterrarlos con ajos semillas de
Amapola y también está Carlos quemarlos
o mutilarlos
la tradición del vampirismo siguió
siendo común hasta el siglo 18 cuando
Serbia se encontró entre dos grandes
poderes la monarquía de los Habsburgo y
el Imperio otomano
soldados austriacos y empleados
estatales observaron y documentaron los
extraños rituales de entierro y sus
reportes se difundieron enormemente la
histeria por los vampiros se descontroló
tanto que en 1755 la Emperatriz
austriaca debió enviar a su médico
personal él investigó Y puso fin a los
rumores con una reputación científica
exhaustiva el pánico se apaciguó pero el
vampiro ya había calado hondo en la
imaginación de La Europa occidental con
obras como el vampiro en 1819 y Carmela
de Joseph Sheridan leffanum en 1872
este último libro influyó enormemente un
joven Irlandés llamado bram stoker
stalker quien nació en dublín en 1847
sufrió de una enfermedad desconocida que
lo tuvo postrado hasta los 7 años
durante ese tiempo su madre le leyó
cuentos tradicionales y verdaderas
historias de terror incluida sus propias
experiencias durante el brote de cólera
de 1832
allí le describió a las víctimas
enterradas vivas en fosas comunes
más adelante Soccer escribió historias
de fantasía romance y Aventura y en 1897
Drácula
aunque se cree que el nombre del Villano
principal está basado en la histórica
figura de Black III Drácula o Black el
empalador la asociación se debe en mayor
parte a que comparten el nombre los
demás elementos y personajes fueron
inspirados directa e indirectamente por
muchas obras de la época victoriana como
El misterioso extraño la novela tuvo un
éxito moderado en su estreno y no fue
una de las obras más conocidas de
stalker que se mencionó brevemente en su
obituario de 1912
pero la lucha por los derechos de autor
cambiaría drásticamente el destino de
Drácula y lo catapultaría al renombre
literario en 1922 un estudio alemán
adaptó la novela al cine con nosferatu
la clásica película muda sin pagar
regalías
a pesar de cambiar los nombres y algunos
puntos del argumento los paralelos eran
evidentes y el estudio fue enjuiciado y
quebró para prevenir más intentos de
plagio la viuda de stoker decidió
brindar los derechos de autor a la
versión teatral de Drácula y aprobó la
producción de la obra por un amigo de la
familia Hamilton Jean Aunque la
adaptación de Jean le hizo cortes
drásticos a la historia se volvió un
clásico gracias a la actuación de bella
lugosi en Broadway lugosi también actuó
para universal en la versión
cinematográfica de 1931 y le dio al
personaje Muchas de sus características
propias a partir de ese momento Drácula
ha sido adaptado incontables veces y
encontró la vida eterna Más allá de las
Humildes páginas de su nacimiento
[Música]
continúe explorando el mundo de la
literatura clásica con estos videos y no
olvides suscribirse a nuestro canal para
no perderse nunca otra lección que valga
la pena compartir
[Música]